معنا من القدس مسؤول التواصل في منظمه
اليونسيف بالاراضي الفلسطينيه جوناثان
كريكس اهلا بك معنا كيف تقيم الالتزام
الاسرائيلي بهذه الهدنه خاصه انه وردنا
استهداف لكوادر طبيه في المستشفيات من
جانب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
القطاع
اولا ما نلاحظه وما اريد ان اقوله هو ان
اليونسف ترحب بالهد المؤقته في القتال
لانها
توفر فرصه راحه صغيره جدا
للاطفال الذين عرضوا لعنف شديد للغايه في
الاسابيع
الماضيه ويجب ان ندرك ان الحاجات للغايه
بالنسبه
لنا حاليا المساعدات الانسانيه التي يتم
ارسالها الى غزه لها اهميه حيويه
للغايه نعم برايك هل هذه المساعدات
التي دخلت حتى الان كافيه
وستساعد من تضرروا
بربما الاكتفاء باحتياجاتهم الطبيه
الغذائيه والى ما
هنالك
ان الامم المتحده وال يونيسيف وكل شركائنا
نفعل ما نستطيع
لايصال اكبر قدر ممكن من المساعدات
الانسانيه الى غزه يوم امس اكثر من 130
شاحنه محمله بمختلف البضائع ومن مختلف
الوكالات وال
والوقود ايضا دخلت الى غزه وهذا امر مهم
للغايه لان الحاجات هائله وما سمعناه هو
ان هذا اليوم نعم اكبر القافلات التي دخلت
الى غزه اليوم كانت الاكبر في شهر وما
ينبغي ان لا يغيب عن الاذهان ان هذه
المساعدات تتضمن طعاما ومياه
ومستلزمات طبيه وهي لها اهميه قصوى خاصه
بالنسبه للاطفال في قطاع غزه بما ان منظمه
اليونيسف معنيه بالاطفال هل من خطوات
ستقومون بها بخصوص 6000 طفل الذين لا
يزالون تحت الانقاد في قطاع
غزه
هنا على سبيل المثال ياتي دور الوقود
واهميته ما نحتاج الى كميات كافيه من
الوقود التي تدخل الى غزه لكي تستطيع
الحفارات
والالات ازاله الانقاظ
ورفع
العنها او رفعا الاطفال كما
تعلمون هذا ما تطالب به
سف من قبل نحن نطالب بارسال المياه
والطعام والمستلزمات الطبيه والوقود ايضا
ولهذا السبب او احد الاسباب الذي يجعل من
الوقود ضروره ان يرسل الان لاخراج الاطفال
من تحت الانقاض نعم ماذا عن الاطفال الذين
لا يزالون في العراء بعد ان فقدوا منازلهم
ونحن على ابواب فصل
الشتاء طواقمنا الموجود على الارض التقت
بالكثير من هؤلاء الاطفال صحيح ان وضعهم
وخاصه في الاطفال الذين فصلوا عن عائلاتهم
التقينا باطفال فقدوا ابائهم واخوانهم
واخواتهم اليونيسيف تنشط
في هذا المجال في مراقبه هؤلاء
ومحاوله ايجاد السبل
لحمايتهم فكما تعلمون ان هؤلاء الاطفال
الذين فقدوا ذويهم هم من بين الاطفال
الاكثر ضعفا وهشاشه في الظروف السيئه التي
نعيشها الان اليونسف تعمل على ذلك وتوفر
الدعم على الارض وهذه من بين مهامنا
الاساسيه هناك رب ربما لو تسمح لي بشكل
سريع الاعتناء بالحاله النفسيه لهؤلاء
الاطفال لا يقل اهميه عن ادخال المساعدات
وبالتالي ما الذي ستقومون به على هذا
الصعيد بايجاز لو
سمحت نعم هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه واريد ان
اشارككم نقطه بان احدى زميلاتي من يونيسيف
لدي
واح عمرها سنوات والاخرى سب سنوات فحتى هي
وجدت صعوبه في جعل بناتها يحصلون على قليل
من الماء وقليل من الطعام وعندما كنا نبحث
هذه القضيه منها سالنا عن الوضع النفسي
لاطفالها فقالت الان هي كام كفاحها
ومهمتها هو الابقاء عليهما احياء
والمساعده النفسيه ستاتي لاحقا هذا امر
مريع حقيقه ان نقوله لكن هذا هو واقع
الحال نحاول مع شركائنا ان نقدم كل
التدابير للمساعده المساعده النفسيه
والاجتماعيه ومن بين المساعدات التي نخطط
لادخالها الى قطاع غزه في المستقبل تتضمن
عناصر
من شانها ان تدعم من الناحيه النفسيه لكن
اود ان اقول شيئا انما يحتاجوا اطفال غزه
اكثر من اي شيء اخر هو السلام فهو امر
ضروري لكي يستطيعوا ان بعد ذلك يتلقوا
دعما نفسيا ما هو مطلوب هو وقف اطلاق نار
انساني والعنف الذي نراه يجب ان يتوقف
الان شكرا لك من القدس مسؤول التواصل في
منظمه اليونسف بالاراضي الفلسطينيه
جوناثان
ك